Transcription is the first step of
making a protein from DNA instructions.
Our genome is made of DNA. The genome
is like a huge book full of
instructions, and a gene is a set of
instructions for making a single
protein. Cells first copy just one gene
and send this copy to a factory in the
cell, called a ribosome, which will use
the instructions to build a protein.
Scientists refer to the copying process
as transcription, since transcribing
means making copies. So how does
transcription work?
DNA consists of two strands wrapped
around each other to form a double
helix, like a twisted ladder.
Let's untwist it and take a closer look.
The rungs of the ladder are made by
only four bases, denoted by the letters
A, T, G and C. To understand
transcription, we need to remember a
simple but crucial rule-- A always
pairs with T, and G always pairs with C.
This is called the base pairing rule,
which is used to copy the entire genome
from one cell to the next, and it's
used for transcription.
The cell uses RNA to make the copy of
one strand of a single DNA gene, and
transcription is when a machine, known
as an enzyme, called RNA polymerase
uses the base pairing rule to make this
RNA copy. RNA and DNA are very similar,
but RNA uses the base U instead of the
base T. Just like T, U pairs with A, so
the cell still follows the base pairing
rule to make an RNA copy of a DNA gene.
In many cases, the RNA is further
modified in a couple of interesting
ways to make a messenger RNA, or mRNA.
This mRNA is then used as instructions
to make a protein. That's how
transcription works. In this sketch,
we've focused on mRNA, which is used to
make thousands of protein machines in
your body. However, there are several
other types of RNA that perform other
useful tasks in the cell. All of these
RNAs are produced by transcription.